(orchestral music)
- [Narrator] Tea is the most
popular drink in the world.
And there are countless
ways we make and consume it.
But if you want to drink
tea in the oldest way
we still know of, you'll
first need to hike deep
into the remote Tea
Mountains of southwest China
and hand-pick leaves
and buds from tea trees
that are hundreds of years old.
It's a long way to go
for authentic Chinese tea,
but one person is doing it.
- My name's Shunan Teng.
I'm the owner of Tea Drunk,
which is a teahouse in New York City.
We specialize in historic Chinese tea.
Historic teas really represent
the pinnacle of tea culture.
And these teas are
usually not mass produced
and they try to be as authentic
to the tea as possible.
It’s almost like a masterpiece of
music played versus a practice
or a original piece of
artwork versus the copies.
- [Narrator] The masterpiece
tea, so to speak,
comes from ancient tea
trees that grow in the wild.
They only bud for 15 days out of the year.
So Shunan must race each
spring to find the trees
and harvest them in time with
the help of local farmers.
- The best tea trees are always on some
of the hardest to get to places.
Because they need to be
on very steep slopes.
We usually motorcycle a little bit.
Sometimes we tread water.
Sometimes we climb.
In this region, it's not
uncommon for tea trees
to grow for several hundred years.
These tea trees right
now, is at it's prime
and this is what tea
is meant to taste like.
Mm, tasty.
Once we pick the tea,
we need to spread it out
in a whole area where
the water can travel out
before we can wok fry the tea.
This step is to kill the enzymes,
so the tea fermentation can be stopped.
Then we take the tea leaves
out and then we roll the tea.
Once the sun dry the tea,
you need to pick out any discoloration.
This sorting process usually
takes months to finish
because we do have to do them one by one
with every single tea.
- [Narrator] Months will
go by before this tea
is ready to be poured out.
But the journey is well
worth it to Shunan.
- Those extreme fine points in taste
that tea offers us,
I think it provides us [with] a level of joy
that's beyond anything else.
And my job here is to preserve this art.
And hopefully even push
it to a new height.